all right so we were struggling to get
an actual birth of a cab on video but
they're really cute when they come out
and they're little news and then they
get up on their little wobbly legs and
you're watching her walk for the first
time but anyway Brandon was able to
catch this footage and he called you
ahsoka but it's because we you know
we're odd honestly we're taking care of
these animals so they come first not
taking footage of them so it took us a
minute to get this but um here we go by
popular demand hope you like it
[Music]
calving season basically is well into
the name
[Music]
the mamas are dropping all the little
calves and they're running around and we
have 420 cattle right now so they're all
having babies it's just kind of really
cute I didn't grow up in this kind of
environment but my husband worked cattle
ranches with his friend Bryan up in
Wyoming growing up and he's used to it
but yeah it's pretty cool to like come
over and just see a little bit gasps and
man and one followed River but she was
adorable
I don't know what the cat thought of his
mom I felt like there's a doorman
followed a river led the little baby
calves into the bin with its mama
a lot of the cows will just have their
calves out in the past year like out on
the land over 100 but some of them need
help and then a lot of times my Hudson
was telling me that predators will come
in like we have big lives here and
coyotes and cuz we're in Montana so you
want to make sure that they don't get
them bringing them in for the night we
can keep closer around so you know it's
just a lot that goes into protecting
them
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going